this is your foot huh no this show what
your big toe my pinky toe in my in five
four three two one hello everybody
welcome to another ghetto episode of the
genius brain podcast currently I am
doing this outside on the outside inside
my home because my office is shut down
due to the kovat situation and people be
[ __ ] tongue each other all the time
and there you nasty little [ __ ] yeah
stop touching each other in the [ __ ]
ding dongs
hey we got a Khalif Boyd in the house
yeah it's been a minute it's been a
minute hot minute yeah man yeah man yeah
man be doing my thing jump man jump man
jump man
so I'll tell you this right now that's
the most he's ever said you know when
you look I just woke up on just getting
news back in the day oh yeah this guy
was odd like 12 episodes where he just
sat there and didn't say anything kind
of like what the [ __ ] is going on well
the [ __ ] up thing was that it was my
birthday I was like I got [ __ ] to do
roll with me - just kidding fellas I'm
like all right cool
I'll roll up didn't know it's gonna be
on the episode and y'all roasted me
no one said happy birthday [ __ ] was
crazy it was the worst birthday of my
life just kidding news commenters are so
fascinating I didn't know about this
until I think Jess mentioned that she
was she was telling me that they're just
like forums where people just talk mad
[ __ ] oh yeah I told you like I'm ready
that's already right Jess and you told
me that [ __ ]
and I I went into it I was like damn
these people they're they they're either
the biggest fans of us on earth because
the moment we put something up they're
already talking about it like
live-streaming that [ __ ] yeah they're
just like you know what I can't believe
did David thinks he's so tough he's so
cool I'm like I guess yeah David he's
such a he's so [ __ ] self-absorbed
like all he does is he just always
thinks he's right now he's a [ __ ]
therapist I'm like I get I read it I'm
like cracking the [ __ ] up because
there's people out there that are
sitting there waiting to type something
about how much they either hate me how
much they hate Joe how crazy Bard
is how geo is this how jet ok damn it's
all these half-baked ideas cuz they want
because it's not that culture ever like
I need to get in this first without you
you're I'm fully analyzing what they're
even feeling or observing like really
let it percolate and just like try to
understand it from themselves I feel
like there's so lost in this culture to
try to explain something that they have
no idea what they're saying yeah and I
think the the the biggest thing about it
too that I noticed what they were doing
is they were saying that um I think for
for me to see whether they hate me they
[ __ ] hate me and I just died laughing
because I forgot what I forgot which
comment that I read but it was like
something about oh because you know
genius brain we do the genius suggestion
thing right yeah these [ __ ] these two
guys think they know [ __ ] everything
this provides me of like you know when
you see that's that scene in the movie
where these girls are just talking [ __ ]
in their bedroom everything's he's so
[ __ ] hot yeah he's over here just
giving people [ __ ] life advice from
his personal experiences what you think
you know everything you're like now is
just my life experience I think you're I
think you also remember or mind
listeners like we're not [ __ ]
professional or not so stop listening if
you try to get professional advice like
get professional advice mm-hmm yeah why
be so mad about it like ticket you know
yeah and I think saw it's it's weird
because it's all personal experience and
you could you just take it or leave it
life yes there's no way that could
happen in your life that's what we call
it genius suggestions it's not really
advice it's just more like you know why
is it called genius cuz I'm smart don't
suggest [ __ ] yeah I've gone to learn too
that not everybody's made for the whole
you know Internet cuz uh I think even
for like Mariel the other day we were
she was posting some stuff and she has
her Instagram now that's just for fun
and I created that fir'd for her to kind
of just you know create and then she got
a decent following obviously you know
she's connected to me but you know
people like her for her her own stuff
and then the other day when she was
about to post something on Instagram she
goes I don't know if I should have
posted that I was like what what do you
mean you don't know you shoulda posted
that right she goes um like I don't know
like I feel like it was a little too
much of myself for this I was like don't
go into that space just enjoy this and
just [ __ ] post it yeah
so when you post it just move on from it
because that's just gonna spin into
something else if you know but I think
the most part think most of her
followers are just they know what their
food yeah it's not like she's out there
putting titties and ass like she's
you're just cuz that would cost under
aqus yeah like was she doing I'm like
why she's shown her ass she's just she's
she's like super into Fitness is just
being herself but I think sometimes like
I know I saw a screencap of somebody put
up on their Instagram and and their
Instagram didn't have any likes on it
hmm I don't know what area that is cuz I
know they said that an Instagram they
were going to get rid of seeing
anybody's like oh okay yeah so you
weren't allowed to see that but it
hasn't happened in the United States so
[ __ ] I didn't I don't know I'd be [ __ ]
crazy though that would be dope cuz I
would definitely change the psychology
of how you would even like Mario like
you know just should I post this is
gonna the likes what's yeah that's just
posted up to suppose it up I I think I'm
you know I can kind of relate to that
because when I when I first started to
though I didn't really do stuff to I
want to say I didn't do stuff not to
make it go viral but I had to like the
idea first and foremost and then put it
out right but I dunno like I think in
like the first I think it took me a
couple years to be like [ __ ] this thing
you know I mean I'm like I already have
my name out there I proven that I could
do this space so now I'm just gonna
continue to do what I want but prior to
that that first two years it was like
every I will never miss a video on
Sunday at 12 p.m. ever
unless I'm [ __ ] sick or dying and I
did that [ __ ] consistently for almost
2-3 years and back then like one video a
week was a lot like one video a week was
a [ __ ] a lot and then you know people
started bumping it up to two videos a
week and then it's now is that an
average of five to six and it's like who
the [ __ ] is making [ __ ] it was a [ __ ]
week man right yeah I don't know if the
algorithm cuz I explained to a friend
like when it like the og youtubers and
like the news school and like how about
algorithm [ __ ] over the oh geez and
yeah kind of like I don't know how that
works
so like the PewDiePie or like like how
if you were to get a million views yeah
one video and like the new school got a
million views because it runs on the
same ads right yeah like so what cutie
pie like Oh what PewDiePie like
make more is that I think there's people
who are so what happens for my channel
to and I've and I mentioned this before
where there's like CPMs right so how
much whatever as yet purview and [ __ ] so
for mine I averaged about two dollars
which is the lowest ever get on average
on average is supposed to be five on the
higher and seven to eight some people
get like 10 to 12 depending up to do
streaming or whatever mine is at two
[ __ ] dollars it's because I curse a
lot
I have controversial like topics and
whatever a lot of this is done by their
their BOTS and then there's manual
review where you get to request a review
to see if it could still make ads so if
I can make ads is only $2.00 per each
thing so I'm making less than half of
what a regular content creator makes so
for example there's this one little
weird agent kid that's a box on YouTube
me too this kid has like that I'm not
sure if it's like because he has brain
damage or he just has a thick Asian
accent but but he's like a dope little
boxer like he's dope like he's but he's
not the best but he's yeah he'll [ __ ] me
up he's only like five three or five
four but he'll hug my ass up but I like
watching him right and he put some you
know it's like kind of like in a hood
area and he bosses just about anybody
but he showed his CPMs right so he makes
he makes way less views than me of
course right even if I don't post much
stuff and even if it's just the podcast
stuff and I still make on average like a
million more views a month and he does
he makes three times the amount of my
CPM did I did so his he showed how much
he makes and he showed the screen cap
and I was like damn his retention rate
and his views are less than mine but he
makes three times the amount of money
Wow
that's how low my CPM czar so because he
makes about five to six right so my
channel on average right now I don't get
[ __ ] it's like nineteen hundred a
month right which is nothing that's why
I'm telling people I don't make much
money off this channel so people think
I'm [ __ ] bullshitting I don't I I do
it through everything else now yeah so
it makes 1900 a month and then from 1900
month that kid was making about six
grand and he makes less views less
everything with me Wow in that [ __ ]
wild yeah because his ads are worth more
damn and we got to take care of our vets
like it was like and then
what I found out from that too is just
yeah it's it's about the content and if
your channels [ __ ] your channels [ __ ]
there's no coming back from it they say
that oh we will do manual review or
whatever and then we'll see if your
channels in good standing it doesn't
[ __ ] matter I'm in the system as a
channel that you cannot make ads on so
at this point it's just it doesn't
really [ __ ] matter
yeah damn did you know that yeah thank
you when I was doing about two videos a
week so I used to do a travel log and I
used to do a regular you know talking
[ __ ] heard of nvidia thing it was making
my channels making an average from ten
to twelve thousand dollars a month
that's what i went from ten to twelve
thousand to about 1900 a month in their
[ __ ] crazy as a nuts
yeah people all you should do sketch is
it's like sketches cost money right by
the time i shoot the sketch that's the
whole month yeah yeah you below exactly
so I wish you shoot an average about a
sketch a month and that sketch would
cost about $1000 it's like so I'm not
gonna I'm going to love it for the art I
was like yeah but for us
I gotta keep my life yeah so we have a
couple of so recently I've been on this
Netflix documentaries and this will got
me to watch this documentary called the
case of a Gabriele Fernanda yeah yeah
and I'm pretty sure a lot of you guys
have watched that [ __ ] documentary
but that [ __ ] doc is crazy dude yeah
it's really really really disturbing and
disheartening and it makes me mad when I
was watching it the first thing I did it
was right after I was training
kickboxing and I came home first thing I
do when I kick box if I'm not going out
to eat I make something to eat so I
grabbed a bunch of food super excited
you know I sat down and in this
interview of this nurse and she was
describing how his skull felt as she
goes it felt like rice krispies and had
dropped my food I was like nope I don't
lose my appetite over anything but like
a kid's skull being fractured so hard
that when you pressed into it it felt
like crunching rice krispies yeah almost
made me throw up yeah man just way to be
stuck they opened up that documentary
was this why you just gonna believe it
because it was a [ __ ] train wreck you
just couldn't believe that innocent
child kiss succumb or not succumb but be
tortured in such a way and like in
always like beyond imagination like some
person out there was really testing the
limits of
cruelty and you know it was we those are
the documentary that baby laughs so
[ __ ] hard and this is why I don't
watch serious [ __ ] with people because
people will judge me because I have to
explain my train of thought but there's
this one part so when they're going
through their trial right they have all
the jurors there they're trying to get
this guy to be convicted for the death
sentence right or the the mom or the dad
it was the death it was a dead yeah or
the boyfriend any boyfriend trying to
get him convicted on a death sentence
right to see that if it was what were
1st or 2nd degree murder or whatever
those if there wasn't a 10th oh right
premeditated and the one guy that
wouldn't do it was an Asian and I
cracked the [ __ ] dude because they're
talking essentially what's happening to
this documentary every jurors pissed at
it yeah they're like what do you mean
like he intended to kill the child but
the guy's like I'm a civil engineer
basically you say is I have my [ __ ]
smart [ __ ] right I know what the
[ __ ] they say yeah you don't have that
you don't have a death to murder someone
on his hands on his judgment which which
is a huge responsibility yeah I thought
he was actually though emotionally I
sided with the other jurors and I did
understand what he was saying right he
goes I have to understand know that this
man had an intent to purposely kill this
child in order for him to have this
conviction he goes I know he's a piece
of [ __ ] he should be punished for it
he's a [ __ ] monster just say that
yeah he knows that he acknowledges all
that [ __ ] he goes but this is what the
law is yeah the law says that he needed
to have a pre made it meditated plan to
kill this child and he goes I don't
believe that's what it is I think there
was a guy that's a [ __ ] dumbass and
he's a monster and he didn't realize
what the damage that he could do to kill
a child even though he was trying to
hurt him severely on purpose yeah but
the kill part is different because now
now I'm gonna be a murderer for
convicting somebody of something that I
don't believe that they'd be intent to
do right right which made sense it did
it did which is scary to acknowledge can
you could you have you ever been on a
jerk I haven't done that [ __ ] either
yeah not yet
have you ever yeah everybody well I got
called for but I couldn't because I just
opened up we just opened up go for broke
at the time mm-hm and that was I thought
we were writing that thing I was like
there's no way there's only two people
running this where to come
so you told him that I just learned a
new business I can't yeah and I showed
them the the whatever everything I in
whatever I was like I just started this
business like I can't leave for two
weeks to like we just started this
yesterday yeah and so I didn't go I
don't know what I mean
curious I'm pretty Shh I feel like maybe
this is a memory created but I feel like
I did get a mail something mailed to me
and didn't respond to it and I heard
that no you can't they can't do [ __ ]
yeah
but they do try it three times but I've
elation I've only had been because if
they send the mail to an address that
you don't live at right and you don't
get it they only do it through mail so
it's like how the [ __ ] were we supposed
to see this really one that no that was
from my my improv class we're like if
you get a a running red light ticket at
intersection that you don't have to pay
it all this is so much there's so many
variables and like yet they can
literally have the picture of you on
this ticket but then you can say that's
not me that's someone else driving that
[ __ ] yeah I think that's like a loophole
yeah I hope so man yeah yo I swear to
God if I get a [ __ ] parking ticket
during this quarantine I'm gonna kill
somebody dude
Pasadena parking people are [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah they are worst human
beings I've ever met in my life
I definitely because when I got my
ticket I like finally bought a permit
but on my permit I wrote in big markers
like officer Reyes look at this [ __ ] you
see you in three months I put it right
next to my VIN numbers say like you know
any look it's like ya know your number
is yeah but you bitch-ass [ __ ]
and they look so rinky-dinky they have
the little tiny cars that you just you
when you see you immediately just want
to run over there run over there kick it
they were giving out too so it the
office that I have right now it's in Old
Town Pasadena this is a care building
and outside of it [ __ ] during the
quarantine there's no [ __ ] cars there
right but there's still the [ __ ]
parking people giving people tickets
right I was like there's like six cars
out here my guess is they're the
jurisdictions because I did read article
about how it's too
give space to the businesses are still
open for like take out orders and like
all that stuff it was six cars out there
if you [ __ ] give somebody a ticket
you have to die
you're a monster I'm gonna coffin
they're [ __ ] mad you're guilty I
[ __ ] hate those people but watching
so I guess like if you guys haven't
watched them we're gonna go through it
let me spoil it alert but this kid was
literally I think the way the doc was
setting it up from what I remember was
they number one she didn't even want him
in the first place because she gave him
up to her gay brother right which is
just already a weird thing because the
reason why they said that they were
beating him was because they assumed
that he was gay but they gave him up to
their gay brother and I guess having the
child raised by a homosexual couple is
way worse so they brought him back when
she ate him it's crazy that she
requested to have him because Gabriel
spent eight years with that long a long
time and you see the photos he's sweet
kind lovely beautiful smiling and then
the mother tries to get that will for a
check and requested them but she never
had position of her child it's just
crazy that that's kind of a red flag
like you don't do a background check on
this mother cuz she had a history of
like mental illness yeah
and you it felt like the family was
split especially when they were doing
like the when they're on trial yeah
talking to like the father and like the
father was the ones like I don't believe
in Gabriel being with the gay couple
like this I'm supporting my daughter to
take him back mm-hmm but then also
knowing that Pearl was cycle possessive
woman didn't beat the [ __ ] out of all of
her boyfriends and are all her
boyfriends making a douche who knows
what and then also assaulting her kick
her other kids yeah and this this
documentary basically kind of shows and
what it's exposing is how broken like
our government system is especially when
it comes to child care right but on the
other side which which I do understand
because I have friends who are social
workers and if they are packed with so
much [ __ ] so I I mean this is a very
weird case because on one hand you have
these social workers and there are
people who testify that
like the bait they go through a lot they
have to deal with so many [ __ ] cases
you have no idea so what they're doing
so it's either it's either this number
one that they're so sick of their
[ __ ] job they've had it for so long
that it's secure they could do whatever
the [ __ ] they want right and they don't
actually care about these children
anymore it doesn't happen that way or
number two it's just that they have so
such a huge workload that they can't
really go into the nitty-gritty in the
details of these cases but in this case
specifically it's kind of hard it's like
what's it called what's uh what's it
called the whole the background check on
both of them right right on her anyway
specifically she was [ __ ] crazy how
many times that they were called to go
to that house right it's like I think it
was like 64 visits and like eight open
investigations or something like that
it's ridiculous
you know you know what I mean no matter
what and that and the the greatest thing
about in this doc is that they were
actually trying to prosecute the the
social workers right mmm which is crazy
yeah I mean you saying that like I think
it was like 40 cases to a caseworker or
whatever and like but in this case it's
almost like it felt like that was her
excuse like there's no way if especially
the case the boss of the caseworkers
there's like there's no way I could keep
up with my employees who have all these
cases like I have my almost yet to do
but for in the case of gay bro it's just
they visited him they never did a visual
body inspection they never took him to
the side being like hey what's going on
they always sided with pearl the one
time that they did talk to the child was
when the cops came over and put him in
the back seat to be like hey your mother
says I you've been lying about your
bruises and if you keep in lying then
we're gonna come back and arrest you
he's just [ __ ] crazy crazy like if I
was a cop and I walked through the door
and I looked at pearl Hernandez's face I
was like you definitely beat him yeah
that's only her [ __ ] face was crazy
like if you if a white man who hated
Mexican people drew a Mexican woman
exactly that's what she looked like she
looked like a races drawing of a Mexican
woman she looked [ __ ] crazy dude yeah
and then what was it like in the
documentary they were showing all of
these pictures
of her past she has like the the typical
like chola [ __ ] eyeliner and
everything I shadow even her parents
were talking about how psychotic she
wasn't that was the weird thing like
there's so many like testimonials of how
unstable she is as a human being and if
you guys see this documentary you'll see
the the type of damage that was done to
him he had cigarette burns on him he had
like lashings he had chain burns they
shot him in the groin area with a BB gun
PB haze so when they when they did an
autopsy on him they actually found Kitty
or dog kitty litter in his stomach
because they say zenkei later yeah so
they made him eat cat [ __ ] and also cat
litter as punishment and they threw him
in a closet to sleep at night yeah and
uh I remember feeling very strongly
about on top of all this up [ __ ] up
[ __ ] is that that that doctor who talked
about his stress at to be talking about
is like a thymus gland and how like
normally it's like 3 to 4 like 5 to 8
grams or something yeah and then when he
did the opposite was like non-existent
so he was under immense stress like it
was just far away he did and I felt
really sad when there wasn't the
elementary school teacher like she had
to look at him every day and maybe she
would see him change into this like very
angry very just this really this kid
who's known just to be like the class
class clown goofball yeah according to
his best friend that black that little
black girl huh know that part - I was
like watching these kids I was like damn
e they talking like adults of [ __ ] yes
they shouldn't have can't do dead man
yeah damn they should not be talking
about this yeah yeah that was my friend
and I was like damn I don't know if I
would have been able to comprehend what
was happening at the age of 12 like that
right right yeah and just hearing the
testimonies of the Gabriel sister and
brother like when they did tell the cops
like yeah Gabriel had to eat feces
that's [ __ ] he's like he really is
like yeah he had to do it that's [ __ ]
crazy they when they the when the the
teacher was talking about I think like
the saddest part for me was when um they
it was it was I think the day before he
died you guys can correct me if I'm
wrong but it was the day before he was
killed it was actually Mother's Day yeah
and then he was making the Mother's Day
car
and no matter what he was going through
how much they beat that kid she he still
wrote a loving Mother's Day card to his
mom because he just wanted her to love
her yeah that's me crying hurt me that
and I was like oh man that that that
that teacher was just mortified and she
I think she called CPS as well yeah she
she called CPS yeah the dude the one of
the workers that was he wasn't even
dealing with the case but he heard of it
I forgot what his connection was to but
he was pissed because one of the other
social workers he goes like hey like you
need to call this in she goes I'm off
the clock
oh yeah yeah yeah it was no it was the
security guard all the security guard
yeah you're a favorite person yeah like
he's like he's like I'm a human dude and
that kid needed help man yeah and like
he was like it's just it just was wrong
yeah like yeah he took upon himself to
go yeah it was like I'm off the clock I
don't want to get in trouble because if
I clock in more hours and that was
interesting because that company was
owned by like a private like Maximus or
some like that yeah and it was like
publicly traded and like they did they
just didn't it would have cost him more
money to like investigate which is what
they're hired to do then - yeah that
this is make any sense it was a very
selfish and people are just very
emotionally checked out is what I felt
from that thing and they just didn't
care and a kid [ __ ] died and it was
like when we talk about died he died and
the worst [ __ ] way possible like I
couldn't even imagine doing that to
somebody let alone a kid no matter how
[ __ ] annoying kids are yeah yeah
doesn't want slap him across the face I
couldn't imagine doing what they did to
that child yeah cuz he going back to
that security guard he's like went back
he was like you saw the kid and the kid
was looking at him and like kind of like
touched the desk mm-hmm he's like when I
saw that kid I could see his body was
like screaming it was screaming to me
and so I had to go back and be like did
you see that kid it came through years I
guess like did you not see his bodies
like yeah so he's being abused it's like
well over clothes like wow we're closed
yeah that's what I'm saying like I
wonder what like why do people get these
jobs like your job but it's not like
their job is easy it's not like the pay
is amazing there has to be a reason why
you decide to be in a position where you
have to do
with these types of cases because if I
knew that I was gonna go into a career
that had to deal with this and the pay
wasn't really that great I better give a
[ __ ] about my job right just because if
you could look at that
he's a very extreme case and if that
case slipped by then what does that say
about the other cases totally that's the
thing that worries me yeah this case was
such a huge red flag yeah and they just
went whatever you would even better had
we'd not known about Gabriele Fernandez
like how do you just not existed I mean
I won't say I mean I know how that
sounds weird but like because it was Oh
40 cases per caseworker but they went
out and acknowledged it and everyone
knew there were so many alarms as a
teacher the security guard what else do
you need you know the cops like yeah I
don't know I mean even though the the
the people who are on the case of social
workers they they were really [ __ ]
all - they were like 60 something years
old they look like [ __ ] alright and they
they falsified like a lot of like
they're jaded from their job yeah and I
feel like that job - there should be
like I know this sounds weird but
because of the how serious their job is
there has to either be check-ins on it
or maybe in a thing like I don't know if
this is even possible but like you say
you can work this job for 15 years
because of the emotional damage that
you'll get from this right I mean you
have to switch into another department
or something because you have workers
like that that have just checked out
they can't even see [ __ ] they just don't
see it right right maybe they could
switch off to another department and
then mentor people below them and then
kind of get them going because when you
emotionally check out on severe cases
like that like people died and that's
what happened to Gabriel Fernandez yeah
that's so [ __ ] sad man yeah man yeah
it's just cuz it just it trickles down
yeah like the LA County and a McCall
like the people on the bores like the
shadow kings yeah which was super scary
like this they responsible for like
billions of dollars and you don't
exactly know what the [ __ ] they do but
they have so much control and power and
they live in these gated communities
away from and that's why I was like them
versus the news reporters of any knives
and like them trying to expose the
corruption that's going on in the city
you know what was [ __ ] crazy - when I
was looking at them in court they had no
emotion whoo - workers no not these
social workers the boy
in Pearl Fernandez oh yeah the mom and
the boyfriend is enough like I know
there's something like don't show
emotion cuz I'm like like a poker face
or something like that but like it was
interesting watching both of them like
how they came into court like whatever
his name is the boyfriend came in with
like the prayer beads mmm and like when
that priest came over and they did that
Telemundo report he was like they trying
to put they trying to make me confess
this murder I did not do it and yeah
he's like praying is like there's such a
disconnect between him him and what's
going on and in this pearl who comes in
with somehow makes like that get the
prison makeup yeah and she's like been
here before I didn't find my Wayne it
almost feels like she's going in there
and trying to like manipulate yeah her
boyfriend still in the court like she's
so she's that strong yeah that's wrong
the craziest part of this documentary
was when they had the audio recording of
her trying to talk to her boyfriend in
the prison cell
yeah she's talking about recollecting
about what they did to Gabriel and that
she's getting [ __ ] horny off that
[ __ ] yeah that was ridiculous she goes
like babe you better not [ __ ] say
anything all right cuz we didn't do
anything like what did you tell them did
you tell them is [ __ ] right remember we
cracked him in there yeah baby and then
you [ __ ] me on the counter I'm like
what did they do that she's like trying
to make him corroborate like just trying
to like [ __ ] with his mind yeah yeah cuz
yeah I'm getting [ __ ] wet right now
right and I'm like can we call this into
something really warden I have a weird
case going on yeah but yeah that that
and just like in was also interesting
just like learning about the boyfriend
through his previous employer oh yeah
that was crazy cuz she was like she
could use guy he's a sweetest guy he
would want to take the scenic route and
show like the people in the nursing home
like a beautiful view yeah who the [ __ ]
is this guy who I think he was if that's
I think that's really what that was the
Asian engineer was talking about and I
think he truly felt that he was
manipulated right by this girl and you
could kind of see
in that moment where she's literally
trying to talk to him in boolean and
through that prison there's a holding
cell yeah I see it right now I
understand what they my agent people
know what's up yeah yeah because I can't
imagine this guy who beat the living
[ __ ] out of this kid and he goes hey so
like can we like just think like the
scenic route and maybe like show the
kids like the beach or the older people
at the beach and then he was so sweet
wait hi to everybody else right but
pearls parents were saying too that she
was very controlling of all of her
boyfriends and they felt that the
boyfriend was it by his demeanor it
almost seemed like he couldn't believe
that he got this a hot girl right right
and even through the was that caught the
UH that the text messages right yeah
yeah she was like oh he did what to you
almost like he was uh trying to beat up
this random dude at the street on the
street that was hitting on his girl and
that's how he was beating up Gabriel
right totally it's like you know them
talk to me like that yeah it's a fight
you're a Chow would you expect me to do
yeah well when I grew up too you know
and like especially in the store like so
like my parents Tori's like in the site
it's kind of like hood part of South
Sacramento and you know growing up
watching some of these kids
mi thought wasn't that great of a kid
either but this is like when I started
becoming old when I was older around
like like 19 or 20 and I would watch
some of these young kids that would come
to the store that I remember what they
were like when I spent them when I was
like 12 and they were like 4 hmm right
and these kids were super bright-eyed
very just inquisitive very sweet kids
and I can clearly [ __ ] remember even
as a 12 year old how some of their
parents would talk to them right and
it's like no not this is like a handful
of certain cases right like it would be
some [ __ ] like the kid was just walking
around they would grab something and
they go hey mom what's this snatch it
out their head and slap the kid upside
the head like don't [ __ ] ask me
here's idea oh [ __ ] like kid can't ask
you what this [ __ ] is how many [ __ ]
times I tell you not to touch it and
they will slap these kids upside the
head and every time they were there they
would just like whoop on them or just
being inquisitive for being a [ __ ]
kid yeah and then you know when I'm 19
or 20 I see these same kids
[ __ ] [ __ ] mm-hmm right I'm like
damn dude it's it's it's weird because
you know children just literally become
a product of the very [ __ ]
environment yeah you know and you don't
know what's gonna happen to them as an
adult's like from all the trauma that
they had received because let's say even
Gabriel survived this case how would he
have been as an adult eating [ __ ] cat
[ __ ] and cat litter dude right I'm
thinking that's normal should be
somebody who like they learn something
different I was talking to you like a
friend a friend time a friend saw me
like she was like where do babies come
from and then the mother told her like
they come from a pill it's like oh and
so she went into the world telling
people that's where babies come from
like until like late until like life or
we're like when she was like a teenager
like she really believed that's [ __ ]
funny right and then so she was like
well how do you get a boy or a girl it's
like oh we have two different pills it's
like there's such a weird stigma taboo
like it's just why do you give
misinformation like like that's some
pretty bad mister for me yes some pretty
yet cuz you go into the world and like
you tell your friend like oh yeah nobody
who's come from the coming pillows like
it's like one of those kids were told in
elementary school I remember in
kindergarten one of these kids believe
that if you I feel like every parent
told their kid this something great you
hold hands with somebody you'll get big
right right yeah Bart told me the story
where he knew he heard about that and
then he was trying to hold every girl's
hair cuz he's trying to get this little
[ __ ] dude used to try to [ __ ]
knock up all these pages right yeah but
I remember yeah they would like they
would say if you hold hands they would
get pregnant or some [ __ ] like that yeah
kids [ __ ] believe that on the
playground yeah yeah that the case is
[ __ ] crazy man if you guys haven't
watched this documentary like first of
all be prepared to cry be prepared to
get angry because it's it's it's
literally one of the most worst cases
I've ever heard about in my life and it
was going on and I never heard of it
yeah the stock good gut wrenching and
the [ __ ] up thing about that when the
boyfriend got shot or got sent to a
chair or whatever and pearl spent the
rest of her life because she pleaded the
case whatever she took the plea two
weeks after that there was a kid I think
it was like Noah Noah hot row same
dynamic the the mother and the boyfriend
abusing the
child mm-hmm and then discs I think I'm
pretty sure the kid's name was no icky
and ultimately passing away yeah it from
the same situation in this same area
yeah I was shocked when they said
California yeah I don't know why I'd
like I feel like I have like a bias
towards our state yeah but when I heard
but when we went to Lancaster that's the
same area that kassars makes it the same
[ __ ] Lancaster is [ __ ] wild if you if
somebody says like you let's go to
Lancaster California just prepare to
just just die yeah no disrespect what no
disrespect master you guys know people
in Lancaster no they don't nobody reps
Lancaster no they don't people know the
Lancaster's cheap hmm yeah yeah nobody
[ __ ] out there like Lancaster for life
homie
have you ever seen the documentary
called the mask you livin hmm so it's
about time I just masculinity like they
did they interview these children these
teenagers and then it interview these
inmates they're at San Quentin like
they're like life and just want to talk
about like their upbringing in like just
a topic of masculinity and like their
word you so where did you learn
masculinity you problem my dad yeah
they're saying like you for obviously
the product environment but also like
they felt like school because of the
social constructs it was like a training
ground to test you every masculinity mmm
like so like boy and girl you can't play
with the girls yet to be with the boys
you can't and there's these terms like
don't be a [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ] so
every like they're pruning any kind of
sign of femininity out of these kids
these kids and making you a hyper
masculine and then I remember like being
pissed off and they were like the the
news and like psychologists saying like
we should remove you know Grand Theft
Auto and all these violent games because
it's doing something subconsciously to
these kids to prove that their boys like
they have to show and prove to their
homies that they're not a [ __ ] ass
[ __ ] a [ __ ] ass [ __ ] and that's and
that and even in sports like you tried
to take the most what would are like the
things of a man like sexual conquests
yeah turns into something football
players are just
money economic wealth and like Ferrari
and guineas chicks buff athletic those
are associated if you're anything less
than that then you're weak yeah a pair
weak and you don't want to fall back and
not be included in your peer group so
that's what that document was talking
about it was just like it's interesting
when you become an adult and you make
those observations in hindsight and you
would wish like our parents but
obviously can't is a generational thing
yeah so I don't know it's a it's a good
document I've seen it's pretty dope it's
I might feel like masculinity too it's
it's definitely a societal thing and
like that that system is there but that
certain level of masculinity is
heightened depending on the the money
bracket that you're into hmm cuz when
you're like older when you're in these
like rich areas and that that concept of
masculinity doesn't [ __ ] matter
because these kids don't have that
stress of somebody trying to [ __ ] him
Jack your [ __ ] mm-hmm like when you when
you come off and you know this is once
again I grew yeah we kind of grew up in
this area so I'm just talking about my
personal spirit when I was younger it's
not like how I think now but now it was
a kid and when I was younger I I
mentioned how many times I got [ __ ]
bullied I had to like break [ __ ] punch
balls you know cause a [ __ ] scene and
just man the [ __ ] up when somebody would
try to jack me right just so I don't get
Punk'd on right you know even you saying
like I have to man the [ __ ] up like that
was something I'm suing your dad told
you to do maybe not even my dad probably
she's a neighborhood neighborhood yeah
yeah that's the neighborhood thing for
sure right or don't be a [ __ ] don't be
a little [ __ ] right you know and I
still use those terms till this day
right right right right you know I don't
know if it's like really toxic or
anything I don't know if it had but I
would use those same terms I guess for
anything like it wouldn't be just just
because I think I've kind of evolved
from that exactly as long as you evolve
for that I think you have the duality I
think you leave out two worlds I think
our generation was caught in between two
or a like masculinity and embracing you
know your vulnerability mm-hmm was in
our generation yeah I were stuck in
between that yeah cuz now it's like the
new generation jimsy whatever it's all
about like being PC and making sure you
know you're aware of the words that
you're using because it does have power
and yeah it does dictate how because it
kind of goes to show just when they say
when you
man up you mean strength and when you
say don't be a don't be a little [ __ ]
or a little girl don't you're being weak
right right and that's that's where
there's that that de lineage of light
right but then you associated with
females and you automatically have that
power shift yeah that's why I made a
conscious choice to call everybody a
[ __ ] you're a little [ __ ] [ __ ] cuz
I'm a woman no cuz cuz you're a [ __ ]
right that's what it is right [ __ ]
[ __ ]
deal with that [ __ ] my like I do agree
there's men that hold masculine anything
is weird cuz like I don't know I feel
like I was just a weird kid too though
like I kind of just um I do I do still
lean towards more that old side of just
like don't be a [ __ ] don't be rich man
to [ __ ] up
how I grew up is gonna be a part of me
till the day I [ __ ] die is in sports
yeah you're injured you get injured um
be a [ __ ] yeah like you be alright yeah
even like the girls that I know that
kickbox they use those terms right so I
don't know how that how that works and
that and that in that context but yeah I
feel like because a bit other part of me
too like I kind of feel like our
generation is kind of getting too much
in their feelings sometimes yeah well
it's it's it started just suede yeah we
were in a good spot and they just got
super form yeah so now it's from here
all the way to here there's no there's
no good medium right now it's like if
you feel a certain way about something
if you have a very specific stance on a
topic either people hate you or they or
that's India they hate you or they love
you that's it there's no like oh you can
have that thought I'm cool with it
whatever move on [ __ ] and even
sometimes to like disagreements are are
not allowed it's like if you disagree
with me you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] right I
hate that [ __ ] like you're supposed to
disagree with people and you should be
okay with disagreeing with them it's
like it's it's whatever unless they went
about it like in an [ __ ] way right
you know yeah I mean there is that
discussion of just acknowledging that
and how do we you know take care of our
boys so that they don't assaults
themselves and salt women and just the
world because I think even in this
documentary called the mask the mask of
men they're talking about mass shootings
I think they're all boys
I've never heard of a female mass
shooter cuz the guns are too heavy for
the girl's name damn yeah yeah so it was
just talking just talking about that
like just if the guns were pink it'd be
different yeah cama
yeah pink camo like [ __ ] that
different Tiger King yeah
we'll talk about that a bit too yeah
yeah just just talking just talking just
having a conversation of boys cuz even a
doctor may talks about like this guy who
comes from art you know like our school
of thought but like really chicken in
cuz I don't remember my dad ever
checking in like hey are you okay I
remember my dad being like oh yeah you
know knowing I don't remember like how
was school I was checking in that was
just a cultural thing or like this
didn't have the ability to communicate
did you die do that now though no he's
older
yeah he does um back at tell it's a very
difficult for him yeah and I'm glad that
I could see that because I know he's
putting an effort and so hopefully after
time where he can like really get past
the [ __ ] of headlines I've like
Trump and like the city and this and
that like he could really talk about who
he is that's what I'm most interested
about as my father instead of like
hearing it from you know the other lady
or from a different relative like I
wanna really get deep down with my dad
it's weird cuz I know your dad had your
dad had that stroke right stroke in a
heart attack and I was big yeah Oh she'd
hit both yeah both yeah yeah yeah I mean
usually when somebody feels their
mortality and I think that's when this
starts to change their perspective I it
was like oh [ __ ] like I almost died
maybe I have to change a few things
about myself and maybe I maybe that's
why he probably open trying to open up a
little more
yeah I'm just wanting I just want to
know how he views the world and now you
know after it you know my grandma his
mother passed away like he doesn't have
that crux anymore yeah and so who did he
talk to like he doesn't talk to the
other lady he doesn't really talk to his
friends he's kind of a loner he's kind
my family always referred to him as a
street rat he was just like out on his
own and I kind of had that same quality
I have like I could go out and be okay
by myself
yeah and just want to do my own thing
but like just talking to him and like
talk he's always talking [ __ ] about like
his sister I'm like do you think he was
it was her fault the way she turned up
because of what I know how you all were
raised he's like no never thought I
don't know maybe oh [ __ ] yeah it's like
oh [ __ ] like okay we're getting
somewhere so every time we FaceTime now
that we're talking more because of the
corn scene on their face time like I
he's been opening up more which is
interesting which is a very long around
bout to get back to what is the big
elephant in the room with my family so
that's such a weird thing because my dad
too I I have a weird experience now
where my dad he asks a lot about if I'm
okay but he'll do it through my mom
because Romano's that you guys have you
have a certain relationship right but
even then like yeah the same person
that's the weird thing I didn't realize
how similar I am to my mom until I
started getting old and I was like damn
she says some crazy [ __ ] and I'm like oh
[ __ ] that's exactly where I get it from
same way she used to get in fights with
my dad to sabers when I get in fights
with Mariel mhm
so the funny thing is is that my dad
because of our relationship when we were
younger he would only ask certain things
about me because he was gonna whup my
ass right so if he was asking like what
are you doing it's more like I know what
you're about to do and wanna [ __ ] you up
because of it and so because of that
previous relationship when I was younger
when he asked me how I'm doing
immediately even if it's [ __ ] small
I'm already pissed mmm even if he's just
asking though
yeah I'm already traumatized from that
yeah yeah [ __ ] so now it's like oh why
are you asking what I'm doing like do
you not think that I'm doing it right do
you are you gonna you know what are you
gonna do and that's the back part of
what my mind and I yeah so I'm like why
am I getting mad when he just asked me
how and I don't really think about that
[ __ ] I was like oh I was wrong cuz like
from it was like a few years back that I
realized this but he just called and he
was like all is everything okay is
everything fine and I'm like why that's
the first thing I said was why Yeah
right he was like what do you mean why
is I'm just asking I was like yeah but
you're not just asking why
so yeah right and then you know led to
an argument we were fighting and then
after I got the phone I was like oh my
mom called me up she goes why are you so
[ __ ] mean to your dad
I say well I was like well he's calling
because I know he wants to say something
else like he's just I don't like the way
he's talking to me he goes he wasn't
talking to you anyway I was right next
next to him he just asked you how are
you doing yeah just I'm seeing like the
wheels turning like he's been operating
like this and you've been traumatized
you know it's swishing back me time dad
because you [ __ ] you know when I was
growing up exactly so as I'm talking to
my mom my mom's mad at me you're upset
she goes like you know your dad's
feelings [ __ ] hurt you just hear me
screaming at the top of his lungs in the
back like I see such a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're the [ __ ] [ __ ] right and I
said then and think about it and I was
like oh [ __ ] like I was actually wrong
in this situation but you know it's not
to make excuses like I every time prior
to that it was because you were trying
to yell at me you were trying to do
something to me all right so now when I
see that I would I when you asked me
some things like I said I see the setup
yeah and I don't want to fall for that
trend right so I had to learn how to
turn that [ __ ] off a few years ago my
phone might be 340 might even be longer
but I learned how to turn that [ __ ] off
and just kind of accepted that he's now
he's just older mm-hmm and he's not in
that state of you know wanting to beat
my ass right now he asks how I'm doing
he's just asking how I'm doing and so
that was the biggest switch that I had
to learn how to turn off and I'm not
gonna lie it's still there
like when he asked I still feel just
even if it's like I was like a speck of
it yeah it's still there yeah I feel
like [ __ ] trying to [ __ ] me
ready but yeah most of the time now is
just him asking because he's like
concerned about how I'm doing he
softened up a lot last few years though
I don't know what the [ __ ] happened but
everything that I learned from my dad is
from my mom though hmm I haven't learned
[ __ ] from him from his own mouth the
only time I learned something from him
was the last big fight we had which was
like seven years ago or something like
that I can't remember how long it was
I'm [ __ ] up the number but it's just
it was a moment where he and I had this
part where he was it was that whole
thing where he was talking about lace
the way that he talks to me and I and I
don't like it and this is that he was
actually being kind of an [ __ ]
and it got to that point where I just uh
he kind of said along the lines of my
success is because of what he's done for
me and I didn't like that because yeah
everybody has a part in my success
anybody who has supported me since day
one but he didn't so it was like when he
said that itches right and again I was
like and I looked at him I go what he
goes he goes yeah like I supported your
dreams to be a comedians remember when
you left I got you this I got you that
camera and I was like that's cool I was
like you didn't support me at all I was
like I was like I'm not sure if you
remember this I was like you don't do
you not remember that time that when I
left to cut when I was going to go to
college I told you that I wanted to go
to a community college first for a
couple of years and then transfer over
to the University that I wanted which
was UC Davis and you said to me verbatim
our brother was there you said to me if
you go to a community college don't ever
think about calling me your father ever
again
that's what my dad I told my dad's going
to Santa Monica colleges you're not
going that college crazy yeah like he
was like you're gonna denounce me as
your son because I'm deciding to go to a
community college and so oh that's what
it was so what he said wasn't the
success to the comedy thing what came
after the first thing he said he goes
why don't you just go to a community
college like I told you that was the
initial when I just remember that that
was the initial did they help you pay
for a girl for college
no you do it through the FAFSA stuff so
I just kind of like oh [ __ ] you know and
then I was like and I was telling he's
using I don't remember that [ __ ] mmm you
don't remember I was like do you beat me
up all the time what the [ __ ] are you
talking about and you know he just got
into this huge yelling match and then he
brought at this point where I mentioned
this on the podcast before he was like
you don't remember that time I told you
that he wanted to be a comedian
I'll send you to comedy College I was
like dead what the [ __ ] is comedy
college there's no such thing as comedy
College right and his [ __ ] dumb ass -
by the way he starts looking - [ __ ] up
and on on the computer right and you
know what he pops up he pops up
he pops up the theater program at like
[ __ ] Columbia I was like I have to
still [ __ ] get into Columbia it was a
Columbia yeah I still have to get into
the [ __ ] Ivy League college you don't
just it's a theater class what the [ __ ]
are you talking about and so you know
even then like he was so petty he didn't
want to admit that he was wrong it was
like you were [ __ ] wrong and when I
told him in that conversation was like
could you imagine how much further I
could have been now if I didn't have to
fight for your approval and fight for
for this and this I was like the only
reason why you approve this is because I
started making money if I didn't make
money every time I came back home to
Sacramento you would talk about how
disappointed you are I mean I was like
those are just facts cuz I understand
now that it's just see doesn't want me
to struggle like we grew up really poor
so he just sees me going down this route
of being poor it's personal to him it's
like I fail as a parent because my kids
poor so I understand that and then what
what happened we had a breakthrough
moment which is the first thing he ever
told me about his own life that he in 30
years I've never heard he goes while I
was 20 something at the time but he was
like okay but I told him I was like you
want a relationship with me and your
older son right I was like we'll never
have that I'll say you know why cuz you
don't know how to talk to me like a
human being
mmm-hmm I'm respect yeah there's no
respect like you still talk to me like
like you give me a say you don't talk to
me you give me commands do this do that
did you do that but you never asked you
never really asked how I'm doing you
never just called me to have a
conversation with the first honest
moment he has ever had with me he goes
he goes I can't do that because I've
never done that in my whole life with
you my own parents he knows when I was
younger I had to take care of your
parents because your grandpa [ __ ] up
right so when we were younger we had we
had a lot of stuff your grandpa just
[ __ ] threw away all his money
I had it be an adult real quick your
older sisters moved to America one other
person denounced me I don't have
relationships because I can't talk to me
because I've never done it you
respecting me to do something I've never
done my whole life so now as an adult I
was like if you don't understand that
I'm 60 something [ __ ] years old he
goes you have to learn how to bend your
will and accommodate me because I can't
change he goes I never ever ever in my
life had a conversation with your
parents who passed away my parents were
passed away
we've never had a conversation like how
are you doing right I can't do it did he
ever
hmm I was like damn that's the first
moment I was like oh [ __ ] like he's he's
like this because of what his parents
did to him you know do you say like do
you love me enough to try I told him I
was like I said he said like he couldn't
do it I was like yeah right at least he
was honest about it he goes I can't do
it right he goes I can't do it and I'm
like oh [ __ ] it's crazy that you like to
have that conversation heaven know about
it and like suppress it enough and like
really lean in on top of his
relationship with his parents like he's
just taken it as fact and yeah knowing
that he is not in control of his life to
break that whatever that relationship he
had and not apply it to you yeah like
it's man it's weird cuz I I do feel kept
my mom told me to one day she goes you
should feel really bad for your dad
because he's somebody who desperately
wants to have this tight-knit family but
he doesn't have the tools to do it yeah
he doesn't have the social tools like
you use like you you have to feel bad
for him because everything that he's
doing right now to try to keep the
family together it's the same thing that
he's doing to push you guys away right
and so he doesn't know what to do so
that's what he talks to me so I could
talk to you because that's the closest
that he can get to having a conversation
with me but now is it's getting a lot
better now like the other night I've
been talking to him he's been just been
able to joke about [ __ ] as we talk on
the phone and the funny thing is the
connecting factor that allowed me to
talk to my dad is when I talk [ __ ] about
Mariel he goes oh that's a problem he
goes your mom is Mariel times 10 right
I'm like telling my mom about some of
the stuff that you know she and I
arguing about at my dad's cracking up me
understand she's not your mom [ __ ] hid
in a dumpster it goes oh very like close
the door you remember that time your mom
went into the squash patch in our
backyard and laid in there for all
and when she woke up she had 70 mosquito
bites so we're bonding over how much
they [ __ ] hate the people that were
in love with and so that's like our
bonding factor right now and that's that
we found the the little segue okay into
us being able to connect on something
because we can't really connect on a lot
of things but what we can do is connect
on how much our significant others piss
us off good yeah at least you have some
angle in what about you and your dad
what's the [ __ ] we're still working on
it
we just man I just tried to like cuz I
know what he's gonna talk about but it's
so superficial that I try to give him
more facts so like he's like I can't
believe you know Trump has 50 60 percent
approval rating like how is that
possible like you're saying like 60% of
Americans really want Trump and I don't
like talking about politics on you know
social media on that [ __ ] but I was like
that you have to understand like what he
said was it's not our problem
and I ever think when I read this likes
noise Charlie Charlie meeting us at this
he said it's not our problem it came
from China China created the virus here
let me give you a bag with sending this
relief package and I'll make it all good
and this is how I'm showing you my
leadership on the on the surface that
looks like leadership that's what you
need and in every single day we've been
seeing Trump we haven't seen anything
from like Biden or Sanders or any other
political figure I mean we've we do know
that they are having these virtual town
meetings and talking about Corona and
this and that but it's not enough to
overcome that amount of times we see
Trump saying some crazy ass [ __ ] so it
doesn't surprise me that people do think
that Trump is doing a good job even
though or you know he's like he's
talking so much crazy [ __ ] yeah how do
you not like he's and you I'm sure
you've seen all those little [ __ ]
videos of like Trump saying this is a
hoax this is not a hoax I knew this was
a pandemic you should have listened to
me the beginning but the beginning said
you said this was a hoax and we got this
under control it's down to zero percent
there's no cases of it and
it's like a hundred thousand and now dr.
fauci whatever is on my phone that's my
phone oh [ __ ] that's my phone yeah dr.
Fauci oh that that that that doctor was
saying like yeah we're having to our
cases of the corona and in the coming
week so like my dad just takes the
Tibbets he can't expound on that at all
sound like I have to like fill him in
and be like oh okay yeah yeah and I said
that article from was it the Athletic
Tribune mhm I said no talking to her Sam
Muriel you come in all right okay
talking about bing gordyn I send you
that article tonight yeah about his
mental health in like he was like
suicidal oh yeah yeah yes I sent that to
music I really like this article thanks
for sending it to me and they will talk
about mental health I'm like did you
fill that did you have the pressures of
that when you were playing basketball
redlands and when you try it out you
know for the Knicks and all that stuff
and we got down into that so I have
these find these articles are similar to
the topics that we talk about and be
like dad read this article read it so we
could talk about it so that's kind of
our into it so you can understand how I
discern things and how he can learn from
me so I could learn from him this was a
brief concise [ __ ] that's how he thinks
or that's how he does yeah that's hard
man yeah cuz you really want to know
about his personal [ __ ] right but then
it's like you could only get like a
small little glimpse yeah just by how he
reads and interprets things yeah it's
like that'd be so funny to you like you
just send him this film was like hey Dad
watch this film about this man who
played basketball it has a black son
yeah is like a kinda reminds me of you
boy yeah anyways yes like I know that I
have to like really you know fan it out
for him to like know this is if that
were the case like I was showing a
vinegars like this is our life yeah like
let's talk about it you know he probably
would you wouldn't maybe it like maybe
he just does that because he doesn't
want to feel all the [ __ ] that happened
he just kind of like pushes it all the
way down so a generation man a certain
certain age and all that [ __ ] seeps out
my dad step adult-like it all came out
and that one huge moment where I
literally told him like you [ __ ] me up
well and he was like at then in that
conversation I think that the part that
kind of really softened me up he was
like but actually that's the first time
I ever saw him cry friend me he's never
cry like I'm talking about I've seen
[ __ ] where he's bald because my brother
hurt his feelings really and I've done
some [ __ ] my edges like but the first
time I ever heard his feelings was that
conversation and then he just said like
I'm a good father like I did the best
that I could and he started tearing up
and I was like [ __ ] this guy's feelings
man yeah that's complex so complex and
so obtuse and just weird man man yeah
it's just it's it's kind of rough man I
mean we're gonna hopefully I won't be
like that when I'm older to [ __ ] I'm
trying not to be yeah I think that's
like the base level like I hope I don't
turn out crazy like my father and then I
could imagine my dad being like cuz
there were times where my dad would wait
for his father like hey I'm gonna pick
you up from the house to go fishing you
know dad's like you know cancelling
plans with his friends and he's just
sitting on this bench in front of his
house out in the middle of Victorville
you just kick him watch the Sun just go
across the horizon and his dad never
shows up and his mom comes his mom comes
out it's like come on boy it doesn't
gonna come that's a dude you know like
he's like I'm not gonna be my dad I'm
never gonna do what he did to me but
[Laughter]
because my cousin I'm just to wrap this
up on this no my cousin he he mentioned
this story where uh we have an older
cousin where I just remembered this fool
just disappeared out of nowhere I was
like did he die I'm like where'd he
[ __ ] go so my cousin is their age gap
is like 11 years so instead of having an
older brother what you have as a father
figure right and I think when you're
super young and you had this guy who was
a cool older brother he has the Mustang
he's all this other stuff and I'm really
close to him youyou kind of idolized him
right and it's it's it's like having a
dad but a really cool dad he's young
he's hip he's in the football team you
know he's dating these cute girls or
what
ever he's a really great artist
everything that I remember from him I
just remember him being the really
really cool cousin right huh
so I don't remember out of nowhere he
comes back hadn't seen it hadn't heard
this guy in 10 years and he goes hey I'm
getting married I want you to be one of
my groomsmen I'm like what the [ __ ] are
you
the [ __ ] like where did you come from
right like I was 18 at this point so he
like he disappeared around when I was
like 9 or 8 or something like that he
just went about his ways or some [ __ ]
and I was like [ __ ] is go where is this
guy and he came back with this you know
beautiful white woman that he was gonna
marry and I was like you want me to be a
groomsman that's what I thought at the
time and then I remember he was just his
rhetoric at the time when he was talking
to me my brother and Mike was like hey
man we should really you know
concentrate on family it's all about
family but when you say that to somebody
who's your younger brother that you
disappeared for damn near 10 years
that's gonna piss him off right and it
pissed him off and I remembered like how
pissed my cousin was he was like the
[ __ ] does he go go off like talking
about family you [ __ ] bounced on me
and it wasn't even so much like my older
brother bounced and my dad bounced on me
is what it felt like this guy who I
idolized who I looked up like I had
nobody in my corner so essentially he
almost grew up like an only child so he
was just like yo and he had this huge
fight with him one time cuz he brought
the concept of family and I think they
had an argument where basically the guy
who left the older cousin his older
brother was saying that he was selfish
and that was the trigger point yeah and
he any I remember he he mentioned that
just to bring it back to your story he
goes I remember when I was a kid how you
would say you would come back on the
weekends and I would sit there with my
toys and I would wait for you to come
and you would never be there and I
didn't know my cousin felt that way but
he would wait with like his toys as a
kid my older brother's coming we're
gonna hang out it's cool didn't call
didn't nothing and then did that every
time over the weekend for like 10 years
until he grew up he didn't have any toys
anymore
he was just becoming himself and he just
didn't expect him to be around just a
little just a moment like that can
freeze you yeah cuz he's he clearly
remembers it and holds it against them
all those years yeah that's when he was
like 20 he's like 30-something now so
remember what he told me about the fight
that they had he was like he was telling
me and I could like feel his pain when
he was talking about it so yeah I told
him like I remember when I was a kid I
had these [ __ ] toys and I was waiting
around for him to come by and I would
just play with them like he's gonna come
he's gonna come this is the day and
nobody would show up yeah I know dude he
stuck there with my stupid [ __ ] toys
and he would toss him off and then next
weekend or a month later he says he's
gonna come by I wouldn't come by all
right and then he would just wait and
wait and wait and that kind of like
[ __ ] up a little bit of their
relationship yeah and I think even till
this day like they still love each other
and stuff and you know it's about family
but there's friction and unless they sit
down and they kind of heal from that and
they write it's just not gonna happen
it's just always gonna be that weirdness
I arguably feel I'm more cold closer to
his brother than he used to him yeah I
mean just gotta be yeah if you're
willing to be vulnerable and like
express that you know her people hurt
people you know that's that's the key to
it that's the key to being like unlocked
if you guys don't even know like how uh
sometimes how funny his dad is like the
reason why I crack up is because like
there's this moment or Cleef sent me
this text it was like you're showing
like what his dad old people don't
believe in virus [ __ ] like they just
they just like yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] we've
seen through words yeah his dad was cool
as a [ __ ] cucumber right he's like
don't believe the hype his basically was
saying write fast for like a week later
as I listened I got this job the same
thing with like I'm never gonna be like
my father I had to wait at the porch
waiting for my bed and I just pictures
you like the [ __ ] is this guy well guys
that wraps up this podcast you guys
could catch this great podcast on all
platforms I've said this in every single
[ __ ] episode Spotify iTunes you know
give us that five star we're just here
to keep you guys company on your commute
funny stories talking about [ __ ] and
we'll see you guys next time you can
follow Khalif at yeah you can find me on
the Instagram Khalif Boyd KH a LIF be
OID and I'm gonna put this out into the
[ __ ] ether we're gonna work on this
film yeah they sure we're gonna actually
[ __ ] write this [ __ ] is gonna be the
dopest film ever I haven't done a film
since [ __ ] and this is the story that I
really want
to work on so it's gonna be [ __ ]
[ __ ] beautiful
don't see y'all next time please